really though what we want to be able to
do is say well how do we tease apart
whether or not these animals these ones
that spend time close to the cat are
whether or not they're less afraid or
they're not are more attracted and so
one way we can do this is we can look in
their brains right so they can't
self-report but we can we can do a lot
to learn the exact state of the brain of
the mouse so here's one example of what
happens in the brain of a mouse of a
rodent that's exposed to a cat so when a
rodents exposed to a cat they're afraid
and then they run away and then if you
look at patterns of neural activity in
their brain you actually see that so
basically what this is is a think of it
like a pathway to ultimate behavior and
what happens is that there's a cat odor
the animal smell something there are
neurons in the olfactory bulb that
respond specifically to the smell of
that cat and then this information gets
kind of pushed downstream to other
different brain regions with the
amygdala and the hypothalamus that
ultimately end up outputting fear
behavior now this looks different in
kind from a male rodent that's exposed
to an estrus female rodent a female in
heat and so what this is is sexual
attraction and when you do that you have
again
neural activity coursing through the
brain that's almost like a reflexive
kind of response and you end up the
behaviors different you end up with
attraction and there are different
pathways different circuits and how this
kind of helps is then we can ask the
following question so we now have the
infected Mouse it's attracted to the cat
and we can kind of choose between two
hypotheses one if it's really attracted
to the animal we would expect the brain
to be similar in its activity to when
you expose a male to a female if it's
afraid but maybe just less afraid you
might expect similar activity to when we
kind of expose the rat to the cat but
maybe just less so or something like
that that's not how the brain works but
something and then
so what we get is some kind of little
column a little column B so we actually
do have the fear response when these
infected animals are exposed to a cat
but we actually do see activity that's
commensurate in the other kind of
regions and the other pathways similar
to it was as if
so here's another way of stating that it
was as if for certain regions of the
brain that respond exclusively to
sexually attractive stimuli to
attraction to female rats It was as if
when these animals were exposed to a cat
that they actually were seeing that or
kind of responding to this this cat
instead of a female rat
[Music]